[Music]
Nope. Come on. Cook your hook. You're on
teni nugget.
Keep going.
So you aren't going to go
like this
and you're not going to obstruct.
This hand is not important. You could do
different things with this hand. You
could do nothing. Doesn't matter. It's
this hand.
Pass that
to this. Pass that to this.
[Music]
Pass it.
Pass here. There it's on. Then that
comes around.
Boom.
And it's Kotagay on his head.
[Music]
It's not you going here. He comes up and
then you go in. That's not it.
He comes down to come to to that arm.
Once he's on that arm, that goes around.
Bring him on to that arm.
Kot on his head.
Okay. How long you make the circle or
not, that's It's you. Okay,
this is all you want. Just uh see where
her momentum it's gone. Well, that's it.
That little adhesion.
So, if she's here until your arm moves
past your shoulder, that's a yongyang
clap. Just the adhesion.
Oh,
>> you all right?
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
Sorry. Okay.
It's not It's not just cosmetic. You're
not going like this.
>> I have to
touch your head.
>> There it is.
>> Touch your head.
Not going yet.
>> And then you stick yourself there.
>> That's not it.
>> I pass your head. I haven't passed it
yet. You did that.
>> Oh, it's not passed. Still not passed.
[Music]
>> You did that.
>> So, you don't do this.
You You don't do that.
Okay. Not going to ever be there.
is finally displayed.
>> It's not about
Then I move this.
[Music]
It's the
I know she's doing her thing. Okay. But
you still going to have to do it. So,
you have a couple of ways. Like if you
try if you try
on her with this hand, she's going to
let go. You're you're never going to get
close. Okay.
So you can use the other hand.
>> See? So when once I turn this hand
brings her There it is. Right there.
You can use your other hand. Okay. This
hand
>> to get you here. Boom. There it is.
I want you on the side of me, not here
with my elbow bent. Outside my outer
rim. You see that? That's not right.
Stay there, please. But this isn't right
either. Okay. This this hand's going to
come in and you're going to come in.
There it is. Okay. And then I turn you
from the side. Of course, what I was
doing was going here.
Right. Boom. Not here. Here.
I just use the other hand. You can go
slow.
Boom. I got to wait for you to get here.
So, don't you haven't turned yet. You're
going this way. Okay.
Boom.
Haven't turned
this way. There it is.
There it is.
Feel the different placement now.
I have to be on the side of your head.
Okay. Try it again. You you you guys are
pulling out.
You have to do some reverse engineering.
Okay. So, you're even if it was my
height in Kihon, the head is higher than
that. So you have to you have there's
some downness. Do do you get that?
>> Right.
>> But if I if I rip, please. But if I'm
making your center go forward, your
head's not going to get down. Do you get
that?
>> Yes.
>> So your head does does have to go down.
Do you see? And I can't make your center
go forward first.
>> Right.
>> So I'm making your head go down
to there. Okay. Got it?
>> All right. Now I have the problem that
energy is going this way and I can't go
back. That's going to clash. So the
energy that's coming down I keep taking
around to let your center go up.
Okay. So, they're here and they they're
not going to come in.
You you'll feel that the the yin yield
is they're keeping it out and you're
here.
So you're trying for not going to work.
Boom.
Lost it. Boom. This way.
If he's in front,
if he gets behind you, it's the reverse.
Okay, we're over here. And it's this
one.
So, just maintain
what you're trying to do. Got it. Boom.
Lose it. Boom.
Find the center again. So, what I'm
doing here is I'm finding the other
control point.
>> Right there. Okay.
If he gives you back, this one and it's
right there.
Just always touching the center.
That's what it feels like.
[Music]
>> Okay. Try it.
>> So, like you're good. You you should you
should know
you should know if she's doing that or
you're doing it. Okay? You should you
should feel that. She's doing it.
So you go to something else. Don't go
here and she does it for you. You you
you can't you're not going to be able to
fix that. U
like that. Do you understand? So you fix
your technique. I'm trying. No, she
didn't do it
there. Now you know that's real. Okay.
Do you understand? Like you can feel
ahead of time if you have the adhesion
and you have the center then do that. So
even though
you're she's she you should feel that
she's in control. You don't have to let
go, do you? Okay. So, one and I can
change it.
So,
she doesn't quite feel it, but
you see I have her center. Do you see?
Okay.
You would feel like don't have it.
That's just her. So, don't do it. Don't
do it. Even if she's here, don't do it.
Do something else. Feel the center.
There's the same weirdy chem.
She did that. Don't do it.
She's doing it.
I want you to stop taking advantage of
that. U want you to chase the feeling,
not the throat. Go.
All right. So, we'll do the emote one,
but it's the same thing like I know he's
turning. Do you see that? And I know you
smell that, but you you have to not have
to you have to bring the yin the yin
into it. So, you you're here your hand
camera over here, please.
You don't want your hand to go back.
Your hand goes forward then back. Okay.
Do you do you understand? So, you're
gonna make contact and then and I'm
exaggerating it there, but so that you
see it.
And again, it's like the back
backstroke. Okay? So, if I was going to
do a backstroke, it's like this.
Okay?
You don't backstroke like that. So, you
come, you're going to come make contact.
It's going to go this way.
[Music]
See, you're in front of her.
You're in front of her. Okay. So, the
other one
and
You have to figure out how do I get
the side of her head? Do you see that?
You You can't do something that's going
to keep it out until I hit the front of
her head. Okay. So, you have to
There it is. Okay. Now, don't smell it.
It goes this way, then that way.
Okay. You go slow. It'll be better on
you. Okay. Just you're going to work on
the two aspects. Cool.
There it is. Then this way.
Then back.
Not here.
It doesn't matter if you go there and
you go with your arm. You see that?
Still not it. You didn't turn her. So
there. This way.
This way.
[Music]
I'll leave that out.
There it is.
This way. That way.
And there's no there's no rule. I mean,
you could go like this.
You just got to find this. Let go. You
just have to find this.
Okay? And there has to be inward energy.
Once you have the inward energy, then
you can get the adhesion. Okay? So, try
put her there.
So, I'm going to put there it is
>> not not over here.
>> Because if my shoulder is here, then my
arms in front of your face and I'm just
using muscle. Okay. So, I put the side
of your head. Then it goes forward. Then
there's it. There it is. Right there.
Somewhere here.
Side of your head. Oh. So, don't dive in
on your own.
Just relax. Okay. So, I'll move I'll
move you. I'll move you. There it is.
Okay. Try it again.